KENNEDY, GERALDO, AND GREG TO
TALK -- AND TO THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
HIGH DRAMA AND WASHINGTON AS
ROBERT MUELLER BREAKS HIS
SCIENCE, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
MAKING THE FIRST PUBLIC
STATEMENT SINCE TAKING OVER THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION TWO YEARS
AGO.
ON COLLUSION, MUELLER SAYS THERE
WAS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
PROVE A BROADER CONSPIRACY
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN
RUSSIA AND WHEN IT COMES TO
OBSTRUCTION, MUELLER SAYS
CHARGING THE PRESIDENT WITH A
CRIME WAS NOT AN OPTION THAT HIS
TEAM COULD CONSIDER.
HE EXPLAINS WHY.
>> IF WE HAD HAD CONFIDENCE THAT
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT COMMIT A
CRIME, WE WOULD HAVE SAID SO.
WE DID NOT HOWEVER MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER HE
DID COMMIT A CRIME, UNDER A
LONG-STANDING DEPARTMENT POLICY,
A PRESIDENT CANNOT BE CHARGED
WITH A FEDERAL CRIME WHILE HE IS
IN OFFICE.
CHARGING THE PRESIDENT WITH A
CRIME WAS THEREFORE NOT AN
OPTION WE COULD CONSIDER.
IT WOULD BE UNFAIR TO
POTENTIALLY ACCUSE SOMEBODY OF A
CRIME WHEN THERE CAN BE NO
COURT'S RESOLUTION OF ACTUAL
CHARGE.
>> Jesse: BUT IF YOU ARE NOW
LEFT WITH MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS, DO NOT EXPECT THAT TO
CHANGE AT ALL, MUELLER SHUTTING
DOWN DEMOCRATS CALLS FOR HIM TO
TESTIFY ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> I HOPE AND EXPECT THIS TO BE
THE ONLY TIME THAT I WILL SPEAK
TO YOU IN THIS MATTER.
I AM MAKING THAT DECISION
MYSELF, NO ONE HAS TOLD ME
WHETHER I CAN OR SHOULD TESTIFY
OR SPEAK FURTHER ABOUT THIS
MATTER.
THERE HAS BEEN ADDED DISCUSSION
ABOUT AN APPEARANCE BEFORE
CONGRESS.
ANY TESTIMONY WOULD NOT GO
BEYOND OUR REPORT.
AND BEYOND WHAT I'VE SAID HERE
TODAY AND WHAT IS CONTAINED IN
THE WRITTEN WORK.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO SPEAK
FURTHER ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
OR TO COMMENT ON THE ACTIONS OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR
CONGRESS.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
REACTING SAYING THAT THE CASE IS
CLOSED.
A TWEETING "NOTHING CHANGES FROM
THE MUELLER REPORT, THERE WAS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE AND IN OUR
COUNTRY A PERSON IS INNOCENT.
THAT CASE IS CLOSED.
THANK YOU."
SARAH SANDERS ALSO RESPONDING
SAYING "THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
MOVING ON WITH ITS LIFE, AND
EVERYONE ELSE SHOULD DO THE
SAME."
BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS INCLUDING
NADLER AND NANCY PELOSI ARE OUT
FOR BLOOD.
>> AS MUELLER AGAIN HIGHLIGHTED
THIS MORNING, IT IS THE CONGRESS
RESPONSIBILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
LIES, CRIMES, AND OTHER
WRONGDOINGS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WITH RESPECT TO IMPEACHMENT, ALL
OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE, AND
NOTHING SHOULD BE RULED OUT.
>> NOTHING IS OFF THE TABLE.
WE ARE LEGISLATING, WE ARE
INVESTIGATING, AND WE ARE
LITIGATING.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
ESPECIALLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I AM GRAVELY DISAPPOINTMENT IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIA
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEID
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIF
MISREPRESENTATION OF THE MUELLER
REPORT TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Jesse: DESPITE
NANCY PELOSI'S DISAPPOINTMENT,
WILLIAM BARR ACTED IN GOOD FAITH
WITH HIS HANDLING OF THE REPORT.
ALL RIGHT, GERALDO, I LOOK AT
THIS THING AND I AM MORE
CONFUSED, THE COUNTRY IS MORE
DIVIDED, I DON'T THINK HE ADDED
ANY CLARITY TO HIS CONFUSING 400
PAGE REPORT.
>> Geraldo: I ALWAYS LIKE
MUELLER FOR HIS GRAVITAS AND
DIGNITY.
HE SEEMED TO BE A STRAIGHT
SHOOTING GUY.
AND I HAVE NO REASON TO CHANGE
MY OPINION, BUT AS A LAWYER I
WANT TO ANALYZE WHAT HE SAID,
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
HE SAID A NEW LOW BAR IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS -- WHERE THE CRIMINAL
CULPABILITY BEGINS.
HE SAID IF WE HAD CONFIDENCE
THAT THE PRESIDENT CLEARLY DID
NOT COMMIT EIGHT CRIME, IF WE
WOULD HAVE SAID SO.
HE THINKS THAT IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED A
CRIME.
SO THIS IS A BRAND-NEW LEVEL OF
EVIDENTIARY REQUIREMENT.
IT IS ABOUT PROBABLE CAUSE THAT
A CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT I AM GOING
TO GROW AND ANOTHER INCH NEXT
YEAR.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT I WILL PLAY
FOR THE BOSTON RED SOX.
I THINK IT WAS A GRATUITOUS
STATEMENT AND REMIND ME A LOT OF
JAMES COMEY WHEN HE SCREWED
HILLARY CLINTON IN 2016.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM,
IT IS ALMOST AS IF HE HAD TO SAY
SOMETHING BECAUSE HE WAS NOT
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT.
>> Kennedy: BUT IT CAME
DIRECTLY FROM THE REPORT,
MARCH 23RD OR SO WHEN THE REPORT
CAME OUT AND BILL BARR HAD THE
SUMMARY, NOT THE WHOLE REPORT,
BUT THE SUMMARY, IT WAS ACTUALLY
IN BILL BARR'S ORIGINAL LETTER,
THAT EXACT LINE THAT IF THEY
COULD HAVE DONE THAT, THEY
WOULD'VE DONE THAT.
SO I ACTUALLY THINK, JESSE,
THERE IS MORE CLARITY.
I THINK THAT IT SHOWS A LOT OF
THE REPORT IS THE REPORT AND YOU
CAN READ IT OR NOT, AND
SOMETIMES A LITTLE BIT OF THIS
STUFF, BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
LAWYERS, NOT ALL OF US IS LIKE
READING THROUGH GAUZE, I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT WHAT MUELLER
WAS SAYING, YOU CAN SUBPOENA ME,
BUT IF I COME OUT THERE, I WILL
TELL YOU TO READ THE REPORT.
EVERYTHING THAT HE SAID IT IS
ACTUALLY THAT REPORT.
SO I THINK THAT HE REALLY TRIED
TO COLOR INSIDE THE LINES.
HE WAS NOT TRYING TO GO OUT OF
IT.
BUT THERE WAS THIS QUESTION ALL
DAY LONG OF WHETHER THERE WAS A
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN WHAT BILL
BARR SAID IN TERMS OF THE
OBSTRUCTION CASE AND THAT POINT
AND WHAT MUELLER SAID TODAY.
LATER ON, VERY UNUSUAL FROM THE
MUELLER TEAM, THEY RELEASED A
DOCUMENT, AND JERRY DUNN LEAVY
SHOWS IT, SHOWING THE MUELLER
QUOTE AND TO THE BARR QUOTE, AND
SAYING THERE IS NO DISCREPANCY.
THEY DON'T SAY THAT THERE IS NO
DISCREPANCY, BUT THERE IS MORE
CONTEXT AND A SOURCE CLOSE TO
THE OFFICIALS AT THE MUELLER
SCHEME SAID THERE IS NO CONFLICT
OR DAYLIGHT BETWEEN MUELLER AND
BARR.
WHICH IS VERY GOOD NEWS IF YOU
ARE THE TRUMP TEAM.
>> Jesse: BUT LISTENING TO
THEM WAS VERY CONFUSING TO ME,
HE SAYS THAT THE DEFENDANT'S
PROVEN INNOCENT UNLESS AND UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
OKAY.
AND THEN HE SAYS WE CANNOT
DETERMINE ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED
A CRIME, THEREFORE HE MUST BE
PRESUMED INNOCENT.
>> Greg: WHAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT THE CONTRADICTION WAS HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
THEY GET THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT, BUT THEN HE MOVES ONTO
THE PRESIDENT AND BASICALLY SAYS
THAT HE IS GUILTY UNTIL HE IS
EXONERATED, BUT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO DO ANY PROCESS OF
EXONERATION, SO I GOT TO GO, SEE
YOU LATER.
I'M OUT OF HERE.
I KNOW THAT TRUMP IS NOT ABOVE
THE LAW, BUT HE IS NOT BELOW THE
LAW EITHER.
YOU CANNOT JUST THROW THAT OUT
THERE.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE DAD
THAT WENT UPSTAIRS TO LAY DOWN
THE WALL TO THE KIDS, OKAY, NO
MORE PILLOW FIGHTS, LIGHTS OUT,
EVERYBODY GO TO BED.
INSTEAD HE WALKS IN WITH A CRATE
OF RITALIN AND THREW IT OUT THEM
AND SAID, HAVE AT IT FOR THE
NEXT 18 MONTHS.
TO SAY THAT HE COULD NOT SAY AN
UNCHARGED PERSON WAS INNOCENT, I
MEAN, HE ALSO -- OKAY, WE CANNOT
SAY THAT HE DID NOT DO IT.
THAT IS THE SAME AS SAYING WE
CANNOT SAY THAT HE DID DO IT.
I THINK THAT HE WAS GOADED INTO
DOING THIS.
>> Jesse: BY THE MEDIA OR
BOTH?
>> Greg: I THINK THE MEDIA
FORCED HIS HAND, THIS IS THE
FOURTH BITE OF THE ROTTEN APPLE.
THE FIRST WAS THE SUMMARY, THE
MEDIA SPIT IT OUT, THE SECOND
WAS THE RELEASE, THE THIRD WAS
HAVING BARR COME ON, AND THEY
SPIT IT OUT.
NOW IT IS THE PRESS, WHY DO WE
KEEP INDULGING THIS?
I HOPE YOU ARE RIGHT AND I HOPE
THAT IT IS OVER, BUT THE MEDIA
WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
>> Dana: OBVIOUSLY THE
DEMOCRATS WERE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT, THEY WILL PURSUE IT,
BUT THERE IS NOTHING -- MAYBE HE
DID NOT HAVE TO GIVE THE
STATEMENT, BUT NOTHING THAT HE
SAID TODAY WAS NOT IN THE
REPORT.
>> Jesse: AND ALSO SAYING I AM
DONE, OFFICE IS CLOSED, THIS
THING IS THROUGH, KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MORE FORCEFUL AND OUTLINED
IF THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD DONE THAT WAS SO
ILLEGAL, AND IF HE WERE A
PRIVATE PERSON WOULD'VE BEEN
CHARGED WITH THE CRIME, HE
REALLY SHOULD'VE LAY THAT OUT.
AND THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DESCRIBING SOMEONE'S
BEHAVIOR AND APPLYING SOME SORT
OF DISCIPLINE FOR THAT BEHAVIOR.
AND YES, I UNDERSTAND, HE SAID
UNDER A LONG-STANDING DEPARTMENT
OF POLICY A PRESIDENT CANNOT BE
CHARGED WITH A FEDERAL CRIME
WHILE HE IS IN OFFICE, THAT'S
FINE, BUT THERE IS PRECEDENT,
YOU HAVE TWO OTHER SIMILAR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS THAT
LEAD TO IMPEACHMENT WHERE THEY
WERE MUCH MORE FORTHCOMING WITH
THE ACTS THAT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED WHILE IN OFFICE.
AND I WISH HE HAD BEEN MORE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE IF THE
PRESIDENT HAD DONE SOMETHING SO
BAD THAT THIS WAS PASSING IN
CONGRESS, THEN HE SHOULD HAVE
CRAFTED A MUCH BETTER ROAD MAP
FOR THAT.
>> Jesse: HE COULD HAVE SAID,
WE ARE NOT CHARGING HIM, AND
HERE'S WHY.
BUT HE COULD'VE SAID THIS
PRESIDENT DID THIS AND I BELIEVE
HE IS GUILTY OF THIS THE WAY
THAT KEN STARTED WITH
BILL CLINTON.
>> Kennedy: THAT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN A BITE OUT OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
>> Jesse: BUT HE INSTEAD
SUMMARIZED TEN LEGAL THEORIES
FOR A POSSIBLE OBSTRUCTION
CHARGE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY HE DID NOT
SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
>> Kennedy: AND GERALDO IS
RIGHT, YOU HAVE TO START WITH
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
THAT IS THE LEGAL SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY, WHETHER
YOU LIKE IT OR NOT, NO MATTER
HOW BAD THE CRIME IS THAT
SOMEONE HAS COMMITTED.
AND IN GYMNASTICS, YOU DO NOT
START FROM 0 AND BUILD YOUR WAY
UP TO A 10.
YOU START YOUR WAY FROM A 10 AND
WORK YOUR WAY DOWN.
HERE YOU START -- YOU ARE
ASSUMED TO BE AN INNOCENT
PERSON, AND THEN YOU BUILD A
CASE UPON THAT.
AND GERALDO WAS RIGHT, IT IS
CONCEIVABLE.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT DONALD TRUMP
MURDERED 15    15 OLD LADIES.
>> Jesse: MAYBE NOT THAT MANY
OLD LADIES.
WE ARE A 10.
>> Greg: AT BOWLING YOU GET
A 0 AND THEN YOU GET A STRIKE
AND THAT IS A 10.
>> Geraldo: NANCY PELOSI IS